Cindy Crawford and her family traded in
their usual Black Tie attire for full
out punk rock looks for Halloween we
have big plans Rande Gerber who is a
co-founder of casamigos tequila went all
out with his squad for George Clooney's
annual Halloween party in Beverly Hills
Friday night Cindy and her lookalike
daughter kaya were 20 with matching
septum piercings and bright messy
hairdos while the guys rocked black
winged eyeliner with their ensembles et
chatted with Cindy and Randy inside the
bash and they dished on their killer
coordinated costumes we just kind of did
a punk thing tonight yeah Sex Pistols
how long do you take you to put all this
together five went into the closet in 10
or 15 minutes I just didn't brush my
hair done it no yeah it was like four
hours to get cuz we brought the kids too
so anyway it took us for us 24 hours you
get all of us work together what you put
some makeup on and gotta be someone else
for the night I think people really let
let loose and kind of just do their
thing yeah and how much today would you
guys drinking tonight yeah all of it
yeah
you